غالبًا ما يشتمل فن صنع الكوكتيل الجيد على مزيج
من المكونات
ودراسة التقاليد وعقل
الاتجاهات وتزايد عدم وجود
أي كحول سواء كان ذلك للعلاقات الصحية
أو الموكتيلات المريحة
في ازدياد ومن الواضح أن التحدي مع
كوكتيل غير كحولي هو  أنك
تعرف أن الطريقة التي تحمل بها النكهة
مختلفة دائمًا لأنك تعلم أن لديك
رفاهية شيء ما يحتوي حتى على الكحول
للعمل مرحبًا اسمي هل
سأكون النادل الرئيسي هنا في
مستهلكين Linus الذين يأتون إلى هذا الشريط الذي
يأتون إليه بالكامل  التجربة التي قد
تنطوي على تناول كلٍ
من الكوكتيلات الكحولية وغير الكحولية ولكن
التجربة لا تعتمد على
ما يستهلكونه كل يوم ، فسوف
تخلط الكوكتيلات والكوكتيلات على حدٍ سواء
، ويفضل كثيرون آخرون
عبارة الكوكتيلات غير الكحولية
ولكن حتى بدون أي منها  إن النضوج المكلف ، يمكن
لهذه الكوكتيلات غير الكحولية أن
تكلف فاتورة كبيرة بنفسها ، وأعتقد بالتأكيد
أننا نبتعد عن
العالم عندما  إذا كنت تعلم أن الشراب
المغطى بمشروب غازي يشكل كوكتيلًا
غير كحولي ، فإن متوسط
فة الكوكتيل في Lyoness يكلف 17 دولارًا تقريبًا مع
لكوكتيلات غير الكحولية التي تكلف حو
لي 10 دولارات ، فهي أقل ولكن شرب ال
ليل منها قد يعيدك 40 دو
ارًا.  يمكن إرجاعه
إلى المكونات المستخدمة في الكوكتيلات غير الكحولية ،
والعسل النباتي ، وكريم البطاطس محلي الصنع ، والعسل النباتي
، لدينا عناصر
راقية ترتد بتكلفة
ليست كوكتيلات المغص لدينا ، وهي أكثر
تعقيدًا وأكثر تعقيدًا بكثير
.  أكثر تقريبًا مما كانوا عليه في
أي وقت مضى ، لذا فإن الأشخاص الذين
لم يشربوا
الآن يرون أخيرًا شيئًا ذا قيمة
يمكنهم استهلاكه وهم على استعداد
للدفع
إنه مطلوب للاستمتاع بأن
الكوكتيلات غير الكحولية ليست جديدة ولكن
تسارعت بدائل المشروبات الروحية والنبيذ والبيرة في السنوات القليلة الماضية
، ويرى السقاة أن اتجاه
تجربة غير كحولية يتزايد فقط
، وأعتقد أن الطلبات على تجربة
الشرب المخدرة  من المؤكد
أنه سيكون هناك ، وأعتقد أن
الناس أكثر وعيًا بما
يضعونه في أجسادهم ، وأعتقد أن
هناك الكثير من الأشخاص الذين يقومون
بأشياء مذهلة في الوقت الحالي في
صناعة غير كحولية ، وأعتقد أنه
طالما  بينما نواصل وضع أقدامنا على
الغاز ولا نتوانى وسيتحسن الأمر فقط